michelle o'neill
you would never accept a trade border
between northern ireland and the
republic so why should unionists accept
one in the irish sea between northern
ireland and the rest of the uk
well dude i don't want to see any
borders we've said from day one that
brexit wasn't compatible with our peace
agreement with our good friday agreement
i've never wanted to see the
interruptions that we're now
experiencing today i think many of us
here warned against the dangers of
brexit and what it actually would mean
for us in reality and we're facing those
challenges today but we sought
along with the majority of other
political parties sought to find
mitigation against the worst impact of
brexit that comes in the form of the
protocol so it protects our peace
agreement it protects the good fruity
agreement it prevents a hard border on
the island of ireland and it ensures the
continuity of trade across this island
which is obviously flourishing as a
direct result of the protocol even if we
accept that it's there as a result of
brexit
you say it protects the peace process
but it has recently led to the
resignation of the first minister so if
it is destabilizing politics here isn't
it time for you to urge the eu to find
something that wins cross-community
support
well it was never cross-community
support for brexit the majority of
people here the majority of political
parties own across community bases voted
to reject brexit yet in all it's foisted
upon us this tory government boris
johnson has shown at every turn that
they do not care less for the people who
live here it is in fact the british
government that negotiated the protocol
it is in fact then the signed up to an
international treaty which they have
been putting in jeopardy ever since the
the ink was barely dry on the agreement
itself so we are not in an ideal
situation however the protocol does give
us the best protection and does afford
us a lot of opportunity what can you say
to reassure unionists that the protocol
is the best solution
can you reassure them that it is in your
view just a trade border and that you
respect the position of northern ireland
constitutionally as part of the united
kingdom i signed up to the good friday
agreement so it'll be the people here
alone that will decide if there's
constitutional change there'll never be
anything wasted upon people i think
unfortunately for the unionist people
for that wider civic society the
unionist leaders have actually completed
the issue of the protocol and brexit a
mess which they single-handedly
delivered alongside their friends in the
tories and but they have completed that
issue of identity with the issue of
trade which comes about as direct result
of brexit so there are two distinctly
different things there's going to be an
election the polls suggest michelle
o'neill
may be northern ireland's next first
minister
given that the ira campaign is still in
people's memories here it's not that
long ago is northern ireland ready for a
sinn fein first minister
i think it's even crazy that you're even
asking me that question because i think
it'll be the people that will decide who
will there who they will elect who they
will they will decide who will be the
largest party like i come from a
background a republican you know i'm a
proud republican i'm somebody who i
believe can govern for all people not
just those republican tradition but
those from other traditions so to sit
here in 2022 for anybody to question a
nationalist ability to be first minister
to hold a position in the legal
profession you know to hold the position
of justice ministry is just absolutely
madness those days are gone but but it's
not just any nationalist politician it
is for many people a party that is
still considered to be the political
wing of the ira no matter how long we
are past ceasefires and good friday
agreement so what do you say to victims
of ira violence for example who would
still have a difficulty with the sinfin
first minister i think that we're a
society that comes from conflict we've
had a very difficult past we have to
recognize that we've had a very
difficult past we also have to recognize
that we've all had a very different
experience of the past my lived
experience would be very different
perhaps to someone else of my uh my
generation some of my peers but we have
to recognize that but we also have to
deal with the past so this british
government that are intent on trying to
cover over what they did here isn't a
good situation because how do we build
for a better future if we don't properly
deal with the past you talk about the
british trying to cover up the past
you're obviously talking about the
proposed amnesty and historical
prosecution of british army veterans
what's the difference though between
those veterans and and former
paramilitaries be they republican or
loyalist who walked free after the good
friday agreement or who were granted in
the case of many in the ira pardons
well firstly again i mean i do not
support in any shape or form an honesty
of any form for anybody so let me be
very clear about that i am 45 years of
age i'm somebody who has been about the
peace process from this inception i'm
someone who believes in the good freddie
agreement i'm somebody who believes in
dealing with the past so that we all can
move forward together the british
government have tried to block every
step forward in dealing with the past
because for those who say draw a line
under it forget that it happened that
doesn't work the impact of conflict is
inter-generational so today's generation
are still fighting the battles of the
past i don't want my ship that for my
children i don't want it for my
grandchildren i don't want it for
anybody else's children if unionists
attempt to block uh sinn fein first
minister by refusing to nominate a
deputy is it time to consider voluntary
coalition so that one of the smaller
parties could nominate a deputy first
minister
well firstly let me say this the days of
democracy and the terms of unionism
alone are gone and they're never going
to return so it'll be the people along
in this election that will decide who
they wish to govern for them and when it
comes to whether or not there should be
a different form of government you have
to remember that we are society coming
out of conflict you have to remember
that we have special and unique
circumstances here so we can't be
looking towards different systems right
now the good friday agreement was an
agreement that a lot of people put a lot
of hard work into nationalist and
unionists republican and loyalists a lot
of sweat went in to bring about a peace
agreement that's something that i hold
very dearly and something that i will
protect at all turns so i believe in the
system of governance as a necessary
piece of governance because of where
we've come from
there's a lot of speculation that you
will be first minister of northern
ireland and that your party leader mary
lou mcdonald will be the next taoiseach
the next irish prime minister
if that scenario arises
do you think that immediately opens the
door to your referendum on irish unity
well i certainly think that we're closer
than we ever have been previously and i
think now's the time to plan and that's
why we're saying to the irish government
now is the time for them to make the
preparation let's not fall into the
traps that have been fallen to in terms
of brexit make the preparation let's
start to have a healthy conversation
about the things that matter every day
to people what does the health service
look like in a united ireland what does
education look like in the united
ireland so i think that this is a
hopeful conversation because our society
here has lived apart for far too long
because if the last couple of years of
brexit has told us anything is that the
tories will never prioritize the
interests of people here whether you be
unionist nationalist or other earlier
this week people were surprised to hear
your party leader send platinum jubilee
greetings to the queen we've come a long
way from the days when jerry adams was
describing her as mrs windsor
was that just electioneering a reaching
out to the unionist community or the
moderate middle ground community or do
you genuinely respect queen elizabeth of
course i mean i think we have to i mean
we live in a society that's been so
divided and i respect the views of those
of unions that entity those with the
british identity and those people that
look towards the monarchy it's not my
thing but that's okay i can be
respectful enough to understand that for
those for other people in my society who
my community that is important to them
so that's why we sent our best wishes
and you know i do so again today on your
program
michelle o'neill thanks very much thank
you